-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from shows like
"The White Lotus" and "Girls,"
as well as
the film "Obvious Child."
He stars in
"A Friend of the Family,"
which is streaming on Peacock,
with new episodes
premiering Thursdays.
Let's take a look.
-You'd just love it up there.
There's a theater
right next to the fun center.
They put on plays
every weekend.
But -- Oh...
-Well, maybe, you know,
I could come and work
for you there this summer.
Like how I worked
at the freight outlet.
-You know, Dolly,
I hadn't thought of that.
You might have just
solved all our problems.
-Please welcome to the show
Jake Lacy, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Man, thanks for having me.
Thank you, thank you.
-I've been a fan of yours
for a long time.
And I feel like the first act of
your career, if you will,
you were known for
playing nice guys.
And then we did some digging.
These are all just headlines
about you being nice guys
in every show you were in.
-Yeah.
-And then you took a turn in
"White Lotus."
You played maybe --
don't take this the wrong way --
the best [bleep]
in the last 10 years.
-Thank you, thank you.
-But Now you're really --
This is a full --
You're playing
a full monster in this one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, like, "White lotus,"
you hope people go like,
"Oh, am I that guy?
Like, do I treat
people that way?"
And this, if anyone sees it
and goes look like,
"Do I do that?",
you'd be like, "We should --
Someone should --
The authorities
should seek you out."
-Yeah. Right?
You should put yourself
right in jail.
-There's some gray area
about that, you know?
-But you are -- He's a monster
who is presenting as a nice guy.
So I guess it is
pulling on some of your skills.
-Yeah, there's --
It's like, for --
You know, not to be like,
"I'm a bad person,"
but, like, the,
you know, roles that, like,
I've been known for for being,
like, a good guy or a nice guy,
like, that's acting, you know?
-Right.
-It's a role, you know?
-Yeah.
-And then this is
sort of like,
"What if it's not me
doing this role,
but, like, a person doing
that role to everyone
and their family
and community and world
because their motives,
at heart, are horrific?"
-This -- It is
a horrific true story.
You did have the blessing of
the family that was victimized.
That must make a huge difference
when you approach
something like this,
because it seems so sensitive.
-Yeah, Jan Broberg, who --
You know, this is her story,
and she's the girl
who was taken.
This is -- She was a producer
and creatively involved.
And if she hadn't been, I
wouldn't have been a part of it.
Because I think would have just
lent itself to being
voyeuristic and sort of
grotesque in a way.
And she has been so,
like, kind and supportive
and championing
and carries herself
with a level of grace that,
like, I can't even imagine.
-It's a really -- It's a --
I mean, it's a haunting show,
but it is also
incredibly gripping,
and you guys have done
an incredible job.
And I -- You know, it's,
I guess, a little bit over
a year now where you were in,
I feel like,
the show of the year,
"The White Lotus."
And you mentioned the people.
You did play
this character, Shane.
-Yeah.
-And do you get approached
by people who see
a little Shane either in
themselves or loved ones?
-Yeah. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
Like, there's, like,
this sliding scale of people
who come up and are like,
"I saw --"
You know, like,
"I worry that maybe I do that."
And you go, "Oh, that's cool,"
you know?
And then there's people who are
like, "That's me, man!
[ Laughs ] I'm that guy!"
You're like, "Oh.
That's great."
You know?
Or like, "My wife --" You know,
It's, like, always with,
like, their wife there
being like, "He is like that."
They're like,
"She's always telling people!
That's him, you know?"
"Good, good."
-Top to bottom,
what a stellar cast that was.
And, yet, I feel you
probably get this a lot.
What was it like to work with
Jennifer Coolidge?
-She's the -- I mean,
she's incredible, right?
Like -- She -- On our first --
So, we're staying at,
like, the hotel.
And we couldn't leave.
It's a bubble, you know?
And we could order food in.
So, there's like one Thai place
that really crushes it locally.
And -- But they stop taking
orders at 8:00,
and it's like 7:56 or whatever.
And, somehow,
Jennifer's managed to get there
two days later
than the rest of us,
which I also don't know how --
They were like,
"You've got to be here."
And she was like,
"I'll figure it out."
And, so, it's just, like,
down to the wire.
And we're sitting like this,
and Jennifer's here.
I'm like, "Jennifer, do you want
to get in on this order?"
And she was like,
"What do they have?"
Like, show her the thing,
and she's, like, scanning.
She's like,
"What are you having?"
And I was like, "I'm just --
We're so close.
Like, just do it, man!"
And, you know, I'm,
like, kind of trying to be cool.
We've known each other
for six hours.
And also being like, "If you
don't do this, I don't eat.
Like, let's go."
And, finally, she, like,
hands me the phone,
and she turns and she goes,
"You know, you're Shane."
And I was like...
And she's like -- Now when I see
her, she's like, "Mike knows.
Mike knows, man.
Everyone thinks you're a nice
guy, but Mike sees who you are."
I was like, "Okay.
Thank you, Jennifer."
So, I love her, but that's,
like, the foot we got off on
was me like, "Let's go!"
-Yeah.
I do think, though, that is --
As much fun as it would be
to hang out with
Jennifer Coolidge,
needing her to order Thai food
fast would maybe not be...
-So, then, I mean --
Look, Jennifer, I love you.
This is what happened, though.
Then I go, "I'm gonna order
you something."
So we place this order.
It arrives.
And then she disappears.
She's gone for
the rest of the night.
I see her the next day and go
like, "You never got your food."
And she's like,
"I didn't know you ordered it."
I was like...
This was our whole night
was this.
Like...yeah.
-Well, that really is --
I think if you're really Shane,
it's nice to know that
she's really Jennifer Coolidge.
-That's right. That's right.
Two authentic people
finally meeting.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
-Dude, thank you.
-The show is outstanding.
Jake Lacy, everybody.
"A Friend of the Family"
is streaming on Peacock,
with new episodes
premiering Thursdays.
We'll be right back
with music from Pusha T.